la scène est pour le moins surprenante
vous ne rêvez pas ce fonds âgée de
quelques jours à peine prend cette
jument name pour sa mère
quant à la ponette elle n'a pas hésité à
adopter le nouveau né pour le
propriétaire de ce parc animalier de
touraine le spectacle est toujours aussi
fascinant c'est un émerveillement de la
nature c'est comme une naissance c'est
de se dire mais bon sang on cherche des
explications à tout et c'est tellement
plus simple que de laisser la nature
faire les choses nous sommes ici dans la
propriété de la famille de mauléon ces
passionnés d'animaux abrite 70 ch d'un
ou autres cervidés dans leur parc
personnel qu'ils ouvrent régulièrement
au public pour protéger les nouveau nés
des renards qui viennent se nourrir dans
les enclos les propriétaires les met à
l'abri
ils sont donc séparés de leur mère d'où
l'idée de tenter un rapprochement avec
la ponette de la famille tout de suite
un an la jument a défendu ce petit faon
la la protéger et protéger des autres
animaux qui étaient dans l'environnement
immédiat et a guidé de la tête le franc
vers le pic il y est allé tout à fait
naturellement et la succion succion
succion et il faut savoir que le lait de
jument est tout à fait compatible pour
élever un petit ruminant s'est ensuite
atchoum
le chien de la maison qui se chargent de
la toilette du fonds aidés par les
filles du propriétaire
un vrai travail d'équipé sera que tu
fais pour quai l'année prochaine la
famille de mauléon veut retenter
l'expérience avec des ânes l'élevage
ainsi pérénniser participera pleinement
à la préservation de ces espèces dont
certaines en voie d'extinction